to hear you talk about how the car grips
the road
yeah and how tight you are to the road
and that first time you ran around the
track when your dad called you up and
was like meet me at the Raceway don't
ask any questions just be there and
you're like I don't know what's gonna
happen yeah I guess something I get to
do this and you said it was that first
time you're coming down that
straightaway at like a hundred ninety
miles an hour and you're like how in the
[ __ ] am I gonna keep this car on this on
this road going into this turn yeah I
was looking at so you know I've never
been on a big bigger racetrack than a
half-mile which is really a very small
track you're gonna run around 90 mile an
hour there it's a smaller track so I'm
going to Talladega it's a two and a half
mile race track and I'm going down the
back straightaway for the first time and
I'm getting I'm getting up to around a
hundred and sixty hundred seventeen
hundred eighty mile an hour and I'm just
long back straightaway so you're looking
at the corner turn three and it goes
arcs way off around the corner out of
sight you know it just seems so far away
but you can look at it and you're
thinking how's the car gonna stay in
there how's the car not gonna fly out of
the track how is it gonna grip like I've
never felt this before and I've never
been in this situation before to know
that this is going to work and so
physics don't seem like that you know
the car would be kept in the track and
you when you go into the corner and this
is the force the g-forces you kind of go
down and to the right into the seat and
you sink into the seat as you load into
the corner and then in the banking and
that's when you sense like wow this
thing is grabbing this track well it's
like God got ahold of this racetrack
yeah and it's not let go yeah and it's
the most amazing feeling so the best car
you drive no no well yeah the Mercedes I
had a Mercedes that used to be the pace
car for the f1 series that was a very
awesome car that's sweet
but you know it's uh I think I mean our
race cars are so set up to be able to
get a hold of that racetrack they got
these giant tires and they'll just get a
hold of the racetrack so well and
they'll take the corners extremely fast
without it really any real concern but
you push them to the limit you know and
sometimes you go over that limit
[Music]